Oh my god.
Sorry.
Okay.
Whatever.
The trailer first started.
Okay.
Hello.
I might sound weird.
Sorry.
The trailer started so I was like, oh fuck.
Okay.
We gotta watch this trailer.
Yeah.
So I'm sorry.
Do I sound okay?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
Do I?
The audio.
Yes.
I am on a laptop right now.
I don't know if you sound very funny or this mic is not it.
Is it?
It's a very echoey area.
That's me.
Yeah.
All right.
I have no idea what's going on.
Yeah.
I sound like.
There's no way to fix this.
I'm not.
It's a bit tiny.
Do I need to slightly... Do I need to be louder?
It's beautiful as always.
All right.
What about the... Okay.
How about... Yeah.
It's very echoey.
I know.
Oh wait.
Is this Tetris?
This is... This is what they open with?
Tetris?
Okay.
I like how the opening for this is fucking Tetris.
But okay.
It's Tetris effect.
I know.
But I like how they open with Tetris of all games.
Like you know.
It's the first trailer.
And of course the first trailer is Tetris.
All right.
Let me put the alerts a little smaller.
I'm like a little bit scuffed right now.
Hello from A.S.
I'm Tsutsu Nuzuguchi.
I don't know.
I feel like you know.
The very first... The very first trailer should be not Tetris.
I don't know.
Is that just me?
I feel like if it's the first trailer it should be... I don't know.
Something more impressive than Tetris.
You always have to start with a...
Start with an insane thing and end with something even more insane.
It's a choice to open up with that.
That's for sure.
By the way, I'm not home.
If you guys can tell.
I am sort of traveling right now.
It is concert related.
That's why I was disappeared.
Thank you.
And enjoy the rest of State of Play.
All right.
SoundGuy.
I closed my Discord.
So like...
I don't remember... SoundGuy.
Just tell me in chat.
Like if there's anything I have to adjust.
Like my mic or my...
Or the audio of State of Play.
Let me know.
The future.
It isn't just a dream.
It's a promise.
Yeah, I'm not home.
That's why I sound really weird.
When we're turning into reality.
But what about the... the game capture?
Like the... the trailer.
Is the trailer okay?
An advanced generative AI.
Whoa.
We're reshaping the line between...
It's good?
Nice.
All right.
Can we turn up a bit?
You're not sound yet.
What is this?
The fuck is this?
Oh, it's a bait.
Oh, it's a bait trailer.
No, it's bait.
There you are.
What?
All better.
Oh.
What's this?
Capcom!
Oh?
Hang on a second.
New Half-Life game from Capcom.
Capcom bought the rights of Half-Life.
This is Half-Life 3 now.
Oh, what the fuck?
Targets identified.
Neutralizing threats.
Neutralize us?
Oh, shit.
I thought it's not live-service.
We're fine.
Pragmata.
I feel like we saw this trailer- a trailer for this before.
This is not the first time it got announced.
I remember seeing a trailer for this.
Yeah.
Yeah, a very long time ago.
It's very familiar.
Yeah.
Diana.
Hello, Diana.
Also, does sound guy ever talk?
Because I don't know.
Oh, it's real!
2026!
Let's go!
It's real!
It wasn't bait.
Like...
Uh...
Hollow Knight.
It's not Hollow Knight bait.
Oh, what?
Speaking of curry...
What is this?
Okay.
This looks...
Like a very Japanese game.
No!
What the fuck?
What happened to him?
Did he eat his face?
Don't worry.
I made this just in case.
The Dead Gear life support system.
Don't move, okay?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is going...
Excuse me?
What is going on?
Can we...
What?
Excuse...
Okay?
Okay, are we...
What are we playing as?
He's half dead man.
Oh,
he is dead man.
Is this new Pepsi man?
What the fuck?
Is this like...
The spiritual successor to Pepsi man?
Is this...
What the fuck is going on?
Dead man!
Definitely...
This is like...
2025's Pepsi man.
He he he he he he he he he.
You know what this reminds me of?
Lollipop chainsaw.
Dead man.
Woo!
This feels like lollipop chainsaw, but like...
But like, now he's dead man.
Yeah, it's like...
No more heroes.
Oh, that's true!
It does- You're right, no more heroes.
Maybe it's from the creators of no more heroes.
Romeo is a dead man.
He is a dead man.
Oh my god, we...
Guys, I told you guys.
We're getting more games on the PS5, guys.
We're in...
Oh my god, guys!
Finally!
Games!
On the PS5!
Finally!
Oh yeah, thanks.
Thanks, sound guy.
Great butt.
From Grasshopper Manufacturer.
Ha!
Hahahahahaha!
What did they make?
Suda...
uhh...
Suda51?
What games did they make?
Oh, it is No More Heroes!
Ohh!
He's an FBI Investigator?
Oh!
I knew it!
See, Lollipop Chainsaw!
I've never played Normal Heroes, but I've always seen so much about Lollipop Chainsaw, so I was like, oh my god, this reminds me so much of Lollipop Chainsaw.
There's so many games I want to play.
One of my friends tried to bribe me to play Hollow Knight, and then I was like, a thousand dollars, and they were like, oh that's alright, and I was like, per plate, like per part.
I was like, part one, a thousand, part two, a thousand.
Oh, is this the Silent Hill F?
This is Silent Hill F.
Can we pay you?
I want to play Hollow Knight eventually.
Um, I do want to play Hollow Knight, I just have so many games, and I want to play Hollow Knight when Silksaw announces release day.
I'll play it when Silksaw finally announces a release date, and it's not Bane.
So no Hollow Knight then.
I was so surprised I made, um, a Silent Hill based in, uh, like outside of, you know, the town in America.
But it's a nice change of pace, you know?
It's a new setting too.
They're like, not in America this time.
Jesus.
And they're like, based off of more, like, J...
Oh my god, oh...
Look a game I'm not gonna play!
Look!
Oh, it does!
Um, what was it called?
The camera one?
Um...
Jesus, I don't like that.
I don't like that.
I- she reminds me of Grudge, and I don't like that.
I- no, no.
This gives me Grudge PTSD.
Fatal Frame, yeah!
She reminds me of the Fatal Frame protagonist.
I won't.
I- I would watch someone play it.
I- I don't think I'd play Silent Hill again for a while.
Oh my god, well...
I- I can't.
I- I- The...
The Silent Hill 2o Ren Master really fucked me up.
Ha ha ha ha!
It- Thank you for the 500 bitties!
Uh... Validica, thank you!
I'll play Silent Hill F when I hit a million subscribers.
I am not.
I can't.
I- Oh, I can't.
Oh, on a shrine temple too.
Oh, oh my god.
It's like, all my fears.
Oh, thank you for the thousand biddies building.
Thank you.
You traitor.
I can't.
This is like, all my fears.
The fact that some of these monsters are like, sort of look like the Grudge Girl, ain't it for me.
Oh my god.
That, oh my god.
I'm, like, Grudge is like the scariest movie for me.
Not even like the Japanese version of Grudge.
It is like the English NA version of Grudge.
It is for me, the most scariest game, like horror movie for me.
Because that was the movie that fucked me up the most growing up.
I couldn't take a normal shower for...
I literally changed the way I showered.
Because of Grudge.
Because when I first watched it, when my friends forced me to watch Grudge.
Um, because, uh, forced me to watch Grudge.
And, uh, and they did...
You know that scene where...
Oh, I never played Castlevania, too.
The scene where, like, her hand...
Uh, the hand comes out of the hair in the shower scene?
That was an actual perpetual fear of mine for the longest time.
Because I kept thinking a hand was gonna come out whenever I shower.
So I changed the way I showered.
So I never closed my eyes when I showered.
So what I do is I face away from the shower head.
And then I, like, tilt my head up.
And then so, like, it would...
Like, that's how I shower.
And then I also had to get my dog...
Not dad.
The dog...
My...
The dog before dad.
Or I say two dogs before dad.
I would, like, bring him...
His name was, uh, Bobo.
And I would bring him into the shower.
Like, into the bathroom.
So he could, like, guard me.
I had him guard me when I...
When I shower.
Because I...
I was like, alright.
If a ghost shows up, my dog will know.
He can detect the evil.
I don't know what he'll do.
I don't know.
He'll just let me know there's evil.
In my bathroom.
I don't know.
That's...
Oh, bloodstain.
What's bloodstain?
So you've come.
What is it?
What kind of game is bloodstain?
Oh, is...
Oh, Castlevania's accessing?
Oh.
It's Castlevania, but, like, blood.
What's this?
This situation here is critical.
Wouldn't it be crazy if we get a Kingdom Hearts announcement?
Oh, Digimon!
I fucking love Digimon.
Oh, that's so...
It's like Persona Digimon.
Oh, it's like CyberSluh.
Yes, Digital fucking Monsters, you idiot.
It's like the most self-explanatory name.
It's Digital Monsters.
You guys.
We have been enemies for years now.
Fucking stupid child.
But this is the time the Titans have launched an attack on this case.
You dumbass.
You know, the most of the anomalies we can deal with stem from Digimon.
It seems the upcoming battle is truly unavoidable.
The world on this set is running out of time.
If the gate is opened with the digital world in such a state, the human world will most certainly be affected.
You know, I do like, I do like Digimon, but by God, their games are like, mostly un-streamable.
Like, it's, their games are mostly used to be enjoyed by themselves, I feel like.
The world tree has been attacked.
It is just as great.
None of their games are like, actually sort of streamable streamable.
We must protect the world from them.
For this purpose, and this purpose alone were you born.
If that thing opens, then we'll be swarmed by Digimon.
Attack!
Please, everyone, lend me your strength.
Spoken like someone who didn't play- I played Cyber Sleuth?
That game would take me months to complete on stream.
That- No, I have played Cyber Sleuth.
That's why I know.
Maybe years, even.
No, it's worse than Dynasty Warriors.
It's an actual JRPG.
It's-
that's me!
Look!
I'm, there's a chocobo!
I like the mini chocobo's.
The Cheapy chocobo's?
The Cheapy Chocobo's?
I used to read the manga adaptation of the Cheapy Chocobo's, the Cheapy Chocobo's.
You know the Chibi Chocopo dungeon manga.
I used to read the serialization of that on the... I don't remember if it was Coco or Happy Dragon manga...uh...comic.
Whoa!
I never played Tactics.
I actually never... I told you guys, never grew up... I never grew up with Nintendo games or Final Fantasy games growing up.
Because my dad said it was for children.
Even though I was a child.
Even though I am also a child.
My dad was like, these games are for children.
You're not alone.
I'm not buying them.
Here's another meta.
Time to buy the next... Medal of Honor.
Like, fuck, the fifth Medal of Honor game.
Alright, child.
It's time to play Call of Duty.
Let's go.
I played a lot of Medal of Honor, Call of Duty, Battles, growing up.
Your dad teach you well.
My daughter is no Nintendo child.
When I first played it, I laughed so hard, I almost barfed.
Let's check it out.
What is that?
But is there... Is there... Just... Toilet?
Toilet?
What?
Whenever it does... I laughed so hard, I almost barfed.
I feel like it might not be a funny game.
It might... might not be funny.
In baby steps, all you have to do is carefully place one foot in front of the other.
Which is easier said than done.
Is this a walking game?
Okay, that's a streamer game.
To make even the simplest progress.
Oh my god, it's like... Q-Op!
Q-Op on the console!
It's a rage game.
Without a map, the best toilet on the mountain.
Yeah, this is a Q-Op, yeah.
Another Q-Op flavor of the month game.
But guys, we get more games on the PS5!
Look!
Oh my god!
More games on the PlayStation 5!
Oh, that looks cute!
It's like, origami theme.
Can't wait to spend, like, what, how much is a PS5?
400 plus dollars to play, play a game called Baby Steps.
A nimble frog.
A hearty armadillo.
Awww!
That's cute!
And a powerful ape.
Awww!
Alright, his game is cute.
Monkey.
And he rechts a ninety- As a child!
On PS5 later this summer.
Ha.
So.
Ha ha ha ha.
We'll look at what the normal chatters are saying on the stream.
And it's like Bloodborne!
Where Bloodborne?
Bloodborne where?
Ha ha ha ha.
You just like...
It's like when you guys demand Soeksong on the Nintendos Direct.
Hahahaha!
Things never change.
For Sony, it's Bloodborne.
For Nintendo, it's so Sonic.
Yeah, with no release date.
You get like one to two seconds of that trailer, and then you're like satisfied for an entire year.
They're like, alright, we gave them two seconds.
Now we can postpone it for one more year.
Oh, Ninja Gaiden.
We're simple creatures.
This is like a play, right?
Oh,
it's a new game?
Ninja Gaiden Ragebound arrives July 31st on PS5 and PS4.
You know, for Wi-Fi streaming, this is actually pretty good for Wi-Fi.
I'm very surprised.
I was so scared.
I lowered the bit rate so much.
Manage balance and stamina to discover secrets.
Oh...
Hey, wait for me!
Oh, do you know what she reminds?
You know what she looks like?
She looks like that girl from the...
Oh, what's her name?
Oh...
The...
The girl...
Oh my god, she's gonna die just like that game.
Mouthwashing!
Yeah, she looks like the lady from Mouthwashing.
You should try yourself with a demo that arrives later today.
I heard this game was fun.
It's like rock climbing, right?
A difficult game above that.
But there's still a lot of state of play to come.
This next reveal comes from the game preservationist at Digital Eclipse.
Nothing can prepare you for their next collection.
Arriving later this year.
We knew pretty early on that the game was fun to play.
People were excited about it.
The most rewarding part of it is just seeing people react to it.
Tree Fighter?
Oh.
What?
Mortal Kombat?
It was such a shock to see this game.
I was like, I can't believe this game exists.
Wait.
Oh, it's a collection.
Yeah, classic Mortal Kombat collection.
Oh, that's cool.
It became something that added to the mystique of Mortal Kombat.
Yeah.
We're showing you a part of a world that is much larger.
I mean, that's nice.
You don't need an emulator and stuff.
We're gonna actually make money off of people.
Nintendo.
That's my issue.
Like, Nintendo could easily just, you know, bring out more classic games slash collections.
It's a bit of the wild west.
So, you know, make money.
Every part of that game is an expression of who we were and what we wanted.
Instead of, like, vaulting it forever.
Like...
Yeah, but they could easily...
Okay, but they're using so much of that money suing random people.
Like...
Especially...
Especially emulators.
Like...
You know what can...
What can help stop emulation?
If they release the games.
On the modern console.
That's...
Wait, the first fight stick made by PlayStation?
Oh, shit.
That's cool.
Not all the classics.
And they sometimes put it on, like, limited time.
Oh, hey, Metal Gear.
Ha!
That's cute.
Oh, shit.
Metal Gear.
Sorry if I don't have, like, a bigger reaction to Metal Gear.
I have zero...
Never played Metal Gear before in my life.
Other than the...
One with...
The metal...
The robot guy.
React now!
Oh, there's that guy.
Snake.
Socket.
Ha!
Don't let it in here.
React hard!
Oh, my God!
It's Metal Gear Solid!
Did that say 4?
Oh, it's the monkeys, it's the PlayStation monkeys!
Monkeys!
Oh, so cute!
Oh my god!
Is it crazy I reacted harder to the monkeys than I did to Solid Snake.
It's the monkeys!
Oh my god!
It's Ape, it's game!
Let's let it go!
Oh, now that's a good... Oh my god.
Now that... I guess the game is good now.
I... I...
Monkey... Monkey over snake.
See, now I care!
Shining stones imbued with human kinds never-ending dreams.
Oh!
Koei Tecmo!
Since time immemorial...
What game is this?
This power has been the impetus for human wars.
Oh?
Is this Mio?
I've always wanted to play Mio!
Such an ominous atmosphere...
Oh!
There's so many games I want to play!
Fuck!
I want to play Mio too!
I've always wanted to play it.
I've never had time to.
Bloodborne!
Hahahaha!
Guys!
My monitor's off!
Can someone tell me if Bloodborne is coming out yet?
Hahahaha!
Here is my answer!
Oh my god!
It's Bloodborne!
Alright, do I skip Mio 1 to play Mio 2?
Does my...
Guys!
If you squint hard enough, it could technically be Bloodborne!
Hahahaha!
Guys!
I was like, Bloodborne 2!
Let's go!
Hahahaha!
So much to Chow is like, Oh my god!
Bloodborne 2!
To have entered the...
Depths of Hell!
Hahahaha!
There's blood in the...
Technically...
Who might you be worried?
Hahahaha!
Sekiro 3!
Tokugawa...
Takechiyo...
Whoa!
I...
I have no context with that name.
Hahahaha!
Konnichiwa!
Hello!
He said the name!
I'm like, who?
Hahahaha!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Is that Jason Bloodborne?!
Whoo!
Open fields!
John-nito!
Hahahaha!
Yay!
Oh, it's exclusive to PS5.
Don't worry.
Oh, they're demo available today!
Wow!
Today!
Guys, quickly, download it now on your PS5.
All five of you.
The five of you that actually owns a PS5.
A Blood Boy?
Is this Blood Boy cast?
Free to take whatever I need.
Oh my god, it's Medivh.
Oh my god, VR Blood Boy?
Is this...
It's like when they announced Batman Arkham Asylum, an Arkham game for Batman, and then it was like, JK, it's VR.
How pissed off would you feel if they announced Blood Boy but it's in VR?
I can't even imagine.
It's just like the Batman Arkham series.
There would be riots.
Come with more trouble than others.
I can't... So it's like, I can finally hug her.
Yeah, there's some... There's some people out there.
There's two types of people.
One that will be mad.
The other one would be like, finally, I can hug my waifu.
Oh, it's Pieth.
I have no idea what that means.
Boo!
Oh, is this... Is this some Nautica?
Makers of Road 96.
What's that?
Oh.
The guy.
A multiplayer story?
Oh, no.
This might not go well.
This is the guy.
You know what that reminds me of?
That time loop game that died so fucking fast.
Yes.
Yeah, this reminds me of the same concept.
Choose... Oh, I'm gonna follow the rock.
Okay.
This game...
This reminds me of definitely...
This game will be alive for one week.
And it will be so fun for one week.
And then after that...
Like...
After that...
It's not gonna end.
One week is too fun.
I feel like...
So many people are gonna fuck with you.
Yeah, it's gonna be a streamer game.
For one week only.
On the... Especially if it's on the PS5.
Okay, you're right.
One week was too generous.
For three days.
Okay.
I...
I realized it said on...
Exclusive on the PS5.
For three days.
For the last few months it has been in the world of Astro.
Astro Bot launched last September.
To search encouraging feedback.
Even receiving a few others...
Oh!
I wanna play this one too.
I think this game is really fun.
Astro Bot.
What?
Aww.
Way to do updates to it.
That's cute.
Adding yet more new challenging levels.
All of which came at no additional cost.
And today, I am pleased to announce that later this month, you will be able to enjoy five brand new challenge levels in Astro Bot.
For free?
I love free stuff.
New special bots will be there too, including Atsu from Ghost of Yotei.
Alongside other fans' favorites.
But these ones are a surprise.
There's a fox.
And finally, the Astro Bot DualSense wireless controller will return later this year.
With a slight twist.
Wait, it has the eyes!
From all of us, Apti Masobi, thank you all for the amazing reception you gave our game.
And enjoy the rest of the show.
Oh my god!
Wait!
That's actually so cute because the eyes.
Yeah, they jingle jangled for me.
They're like, jingle jangle jangle!
Look at this controller!
Jingle jangle jangle!
They'll be like, oh my god.
Sea remnants.
Don't you react!
That's not true, I reacted to the monkeys too.
I just never played another gear.
I can't say.
What is this?
Is this Monkey Island?
He looks like Monkey Island.
They're on an island.
Is this?
Is this like, um, what's it called?
Um, oh my god!
Action?
Action Monkey Island?
Wait, there's no way!
There's a lot of pirates.
Pirates slash, uh, pirate type games.
Oh my god!
Too hot!
You're dead!
It's skull and bones too!
Wait, is he made of wood?
Is that Pinocchio?
Wait, they're all made of wood!
Arcane?
Oh, they restart!
Oh, is it Roguelike?
Wait, they're restarting the journey.
It's a loop.
Oh, it's literally called Sea Remnants.
Oh, I thought that was the developer name.
Usually they don't show the name of the game at the beginning.
So, I...
Oh!
Scarf!
Oh wait, no, nevermind.
Wait, are those the Scarf people?
And, yeah, Journey!
The Scarf people.
Journey was such a cute game.
Yeah.
I was like, I recognize the...
Um...
I recognize, like, the...
Atmos...
Like, the...
The atmosphere and aesthetic.
Aw!
Aw, it's so cute!
Yeah.
Where are my people that help me travel?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Nice flip.
What is it called?
Tony Hawk?
Tony Hawk Journey.
Wicked.
Journey with...
Yeah, Tony.
Sick flip!
Sad Hawk.
Tony Hawk's Journey to the West.
Hi everyone, I'm Kristin Zutani.
That was a new look at Sword of the Sea, a visually striking adventure from the team behind Abzu, and the Pathless.
That's cute.
We're excited to announce that Sword of the Sea will launch this summer into the PlayStation Plus game catalog.
Oh!
Wait, that means it's free if you have the PlayStation Plus catalog.
On June 17, Remedy brings otherworldly action to game catalog with FBC Firebreak.
In this cooperative FPS set in the Paranatural World of Control, you and two fellow agents must confront and contain the reality warping chaos found within the oldest house.
Fun in short bursts or deep dives, FBC Firebreak launches day one in the game catalog on June 17.
Okay, so that means you have to subscribe to it to even access these games, right?
The PlayStation Plus Classics catalog welcomes several new titles this summer.
The PS2 version of legendary immersive sim Deus Ex?
Oh!
Deus Ex?
Oh my god!
Twisted Metal!
In July, Twisted Metal 3 and Twisted Metal 4 join the service just in time for the second season premiere of Twisted Metal, which arrives July 31st in select countries, including Peacock in the U.S.
Additionally, two of Capcom's most beloved games from the original PlayStation are set to join the console.
Could they use Ex on the controller?
Hmmmm...
Oh my god!
Okay, Resident Evil 3 Nemesis was actually my nightmare.
That was the game that my dad would make me watch and play.
I, like, have, like, flashball PTSD memories of Nemesis breaking through the window.
Days of Play is a two-week event that includes bonus PlayStation Plus content drops, great deals on software and hardware, and more.
Visit PlayStation Blog and PlayStation.com.
No, I will live with that drama for the rest of my life.
His parents cut their own rope to save him.
He watched them fall, then found his way off that mountain.
He was 11 years old.
Thank god it's not all CGI.
He started a grand tour of every major boarding school.
He was always at the top of his class.
Two Raiders?
There is a James Bond.
His superiors all praise his instincts.
Is this James Bond?
Nobody knows what to do with him, Mom.
No.
This is where we get it just elbow.
Ha Ha Ha.
Heh.
Heh heh.
I see him.
All right but Which Bond.
It was ill disciplined, utterly reckless.
WIH means God.
Which Bond is it?
Give me one good reason to put him in a- Johnny English.
The Bond word?
Bond word ? a bullet without a target.
Let's give him one.
Tom Hanks?
What the fuck?
Okay, he looks like the guy from...
Tom Cruise.
Sorry, Tom Cruise?
One of the Toms.
This is Twain.
That guy looks just like Tom Cruise.
Sorry, I got the Toms.
No, it looks like the guy from...
Just Cause.
What?
Tom Cruise.
Yeah, it looks like...
It looks like the Just Cause guy?
Or...
Or Tom Cruise.
Or Uncharted.
Uncharted.
Sorry, Uncharted.
I'm mixing everything up.
The Uncharted guy slash Tom Cruise.
Someone was like Peter Parker.
Wait does!
Wait does look like Tom Holland!
It's all the Toms!
It looks like Tom Holland!
Oh my god, it's like Tom Holland if he like...
Like grew up a little bit.
It's all the Toms.
The Tom Fusion.
Wait I see it!
I see it!
I see Tom Holland!
I see Tom Holland and I see Tom Cruise.
I see Uncharted.
If all the Toms had a baby.
It will turn into James Bond.
John Tom is real!
Bum, bum,
bum, ba-da-da!
Oh my god, it's a classic.
I suppose this is another teachable moment.
Idris Elba?
Is that just Elba next to him?
Oh my god, it's the golden gun!
You get the gold gun!
Tom squared.
Names Bond.
Tom Bond.
Hello, I'm Hakan Abrak, CEO of Iron Tracks.
That's so cool, you get the golden gun.
The one shot gun.
You'll experience James Bond as a young air crewman in the Royal Navy.
No, do you see it?
It looks like Tom Cruise.
It looks just like him.
You see that smile, you know that?
You know that smile he always does in his fucking Mission Impossible films?
It is him!
Harnessing our 25 years of agent expertise.
This is just the beginning of our journey with 007.
And we can't wait to share more with you.
That crazy Scientology smile!
You see it, you see it in the smile.
Oh wait, that's the...
What is it?
The sequel.
The other samurai...
The other samurai sequel.
Uh...
Ghost of Yote.
Yeah, there's so many.
You know, the other...
No, no, no, not that samurai sequel.
The other...
No, no.
Not only Musha 3.
The other one.
No, no not Nioh3.
The other samurai game.
No, no, no.
No, not the new... Not Sekiro.
That samurai game.
The Ghost of Yote.
How many of these games are there?
There's apparently, surprisingly, a lot of samurai games.
A lot of recently released samurai games.
Whoa.
That's a good dog.
Guys, did you know that Minecraft movie is now out on digital download?
I know what.
I'm watching your members.
I'm gonna make you all pay $20.
It's 20.
Guys, it's only $20 to rent.
Don't you fucking dare watch the non-CGI.
The one without the CGI.
That is a good... What the fuck?
This is not marble, right?
What is this?
What?
Wait, what?
Wait, is this...
What?
Oh, my...
Is this...
Marbles versus Capcom?
But, like, is it just all marbles?
They just removed Capcom?
It's just... yeah.
Marbles versus Capcom.
Wait, that looks... I like...
Wait, that looks...
I like...
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's Star-Lord?
Wait, that's Ghost-riding?
Oh, my...
Okay, I'm gonna say the designs, you really... I like the designs.
Yeah, baby!
Okay, the design...
Oh, my God!
Okay, not gonna lie...
These designs...
Fuck.
Dr. Doom...
Oh, my God.
I love, like, people were, like...
Wait, but Dr. Doom...
All Dr. Doom wanted was, like, real...
In general.
Like, he...
There was, like, an alternate universe where Dr. Doom succeeded...
And, like, he actually created a really, really good government.
And, like, um...
A good gov...
What the fuck?
4v4?
Oh, my God!
Yeah, I love...
I love the designs.
Oh, my God.
Mecha...
Mecha Iron Man.
So, there's, like, an alternate universe, um...
Where he, like, actually won and, like, succeeded in, like, becoming, like, the...
The president of the entire fucking world.
And...
But then he actually created a good government.
And, like, people actually were, like, um...
There's no war or whatever or something.
And then...
And then the Fantastic Four was, like, I don't like this!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Marvel token fighting souls.
That shit looks really good!
But...
And then Fantastic Four came in and was, like, Wait, this is wrong!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Peace unacceptable!
Wait, why did they rewind that?
Yeah, I got confused.
Why was there a rewind?
Oh, is this Yakuza?
Marvel?
No, these are the guys that created a Marvel fighting game.
It's still about the Marvel fighting game.
It's just the dev commentary.
Oh, he looks cool!
Woah!
I really like the designs.
I think the designs actually cool.
I think Mecha Iron Man, that vaguely resembles Gundam, is a good choice.
Oh my god!
The inspiration for working on this project...
The fucking Gundam Iron Man!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
And wanting to say, why isn't PlayStation in this space?
So PlayStation...
Yeah, Mecha Iron...
...to bring Marvel back to the forefront of the tag fighting genre.
And that got us really excited because we had worked with them before on successful stuff like the Marvel Spider-Man franchise with Insomniac.
When it came to approaching Marvel, you have to kind of first float the idea and let them know, Hey, you know, we're thinking about approaching a company like Arc System Works to make a fighting game.
We'd love to partner with you to do this really great collaboration.
Would you be interested?
When they named the developer, that really perked up our ears.
It's always refreshing to work with a team that will take on the challenge of tackling Marvel, putting their own spin on it.
And they're just uppercutting that challenge into the stratosphere.
And that's what you get with this team.
I mean, they couldn't make something boring if they tried.
Marvel is actually like monopolizing the gaming sphere now.
So now it's Heal Shooters.
Heal Shooters, fighting games, they're coming back to MOBA.
They're coming back.
They're gonna make another MOBA game.
They're gonna hit up Riot and be like, make us a MOBA game.
But like, not fail.
Because you either do something like this big and bold, or you don't do it at all.
They're gonna be like, Riot, we need you.
The Prophecy.
Yeah, and it failed, didn't it?
They took over TCG.
They took over the TCG with Marvel Snap.
They took over hero shooters.
Now they're trying to get into fighting games.
And now they're gonna contact Riot and be like, we need to complete our Infinity Stones.
Can't wait for the tactical shooting.
MOBA is endgame.
Yeah.
Marvel vs.
Capcom without Capcom.
How did this happen?
It's easy.
Marvel makes more money than Capcom.
They don't need Capcom anymore.
They have enough money to be like, delete.
I mean, they still have a deal.
Oh my god.
I love this suit.
That suit actually... actually is fucking cool.
One of the mantras that we have for this project is...
2XKO?
Yeah, that's gonna be interesting.
Not just the IP, but gameplay mechanics and say, what can we really...
I don't know.
I feel like Riot can pump enough money.
It just depends on who... which game releases first.
Okay, but to be fair, Riot has enough money to keep a game alive.
They have enough money to make sure a game does not die.
It's also the gameplay mechanics and adding in that... what is that pop?
What is gonna be something that's different?
Up until now, you've seen tag fighters that have 2XKO at least has a year before the Marvel game comes out.
I feel like we just had to go 4v4.
And in doing so, we found a lot of unique and fun ways to change up the gameplay that I think players are gonna be very excited to see.
Jesus fucking Christ.
That has a lot of people on my screen.
Oh my god, that moves to look so cool.
Oh my god, the spotty sense!
The spotty sense dodge!
Yeah, what happened on that screen?
I don't know.
There was 8 people there.
Or you can tag in your assist to swap the leader and change the matchup on the fly.
Ah, so it is like Marvel vs.
Capcom.
This game would be here, would come.
This has just been an awesome journey and I'm excited that we get to be able to share it with all the fans out there.
I'll tell you right now, a lot of fighting games, they never get to experience this level production.
Marvel Battle Royale goes hard.
You know how you can play that?
Fortnite.
That's just Fortnite, guys.
And it's free, except when you buy the Marvel Skins.
I think really, I gotta make something magical here.
Yeah, just create a custom lobby and then be like, you can only play if you equip the Marvel Skins.
And then create your own Marvel Battle Royale.
I don't know about Star-Lord.
I think the only skin I don't, the only skin I don't like is Star-Lord.
He looks, I don't, I guess, I mean, Star-Lord is a dweeb in general.
Like, in the end, he is a fucking dweeb.
Um, but like, I don't know.
I don't, I think Star-Lord is the one I'm iffy about.
You're still with me?
Oh?
Is that it?
Oh my god, it's already been an hour?
Oh my, I did not feel like an hour.
All these trailers passed by so fast.
Wait, that was the, that was the ending.
I mean, to be fair, that Marvel trailer was pretty fucking sick.
But I wasn't expecting it.
No Blood Point?
Guys, we still have the Summer Game Fest.
But I don't think we're gonna get Blood Point or Resident Evil.
Yeah, I think the Marvel trailer was pretty fucking sick.
I mean, there were a lot of cool games.
I'm interested in the Pirate Game too.
The Pirate Game seemed really fun.
And the James Bond one.
The James Bond one reminds me of an Indiana Jones.
I mean, those are some good releases.
Silent Hill...
The James...
I feel like the James Bond would be very similar to the Indiana Jones game as well.
I feel like.
It gave me the same vibe.
PlayStation.
That was good.
I feel like it was pretty good.
Um, I mean, it's just from Sony.
So, uh, I think that was a decent state of play.
Um, state of play for me.
There was a lot of games I'm actually looking forward to.
So, uh, just for the PlayStation.
Yeah.
Um, um, not like a lot of...
Not a lot of heavy hitters.
Uh, I mean, like, a lot of the games I was already looking forward to that have already been announced before.
So, like, you know, Neo 3.
Um, the Ghost of Yote.
Um, um, the games I...
And then there's, like, you know, James Bond.
James Bond.
That seemed really interesting.
James Bond one.
And...
The...
The Tom...
Sorry.
Tom Bond.
The Tom Bond game.
And, uh...
Um, that Marvel fighting game looks really fucking sick.
But, like, obviously, as not...
Like, I'm not the best at fighting games.
So...
The name's Tom...
The name's Bond.
Tom Bond.
Um, the pirate...
I think the pirate game looks fun.
I like roguelikes in general.
So...
Um...
So, like...
Uh...
Like, the...
The roguelike for that looks really good.
Um...
Silent Hill F.
I'll play it with a million subscribers.
But, like, other than that...
That actually has a lot of my fucking fears.
The moment I saw that girl that looks like the grudge girl, I was like, no.
No.
When I played the Silent Hill 2 remastered, I was...
I could literally only play two hours...
Two to three hours max.
Three hours is pushing it.
Like, two hours is, like, my comfortable zone.
Before I go, like...
I can't keep playing.
Like...
That was how fucking scared I am.
I was like...
I was literally getting goosebumps.
And, like...
Uh...
My heart was beating.
Like...
Every time I have to play that game.
So, I'm just like...
Ah!
And then...
But then, like...
Oh...
Silent Hill F looks even more freaky.
Because, like...
There's, like...
You know...
Like...
Old cities and stuff like that.
And then it just reminds me of, like...
Like...
Ah...
I just...
I just don't like that.
And then the girl...
The women...
In the game...
The monster looks like...
Fucking grudge.
I'm like...
Oh...
It will be echoing, unfortunately.
Okay.
Uh...
Umm...
So...
I hope you guys can...
Um...
Uh...
We'll be okay...
With this sound...
Set up for the next couple of days, and then I'll be back on my old, old set up.
But yes, thank you all for coming.
I'll talk more about it later today.
There is another... what is it?
Is it Summer Game Fest?
There is Summer Game Fest.
So we have Summer Game Fest on Thursday, I believe, which will announce more and more games.
And yeah, I'm looking forward to checking that out.
But if you guys want to know more about, like, why I'm traveling and all that shit, I will be talking more about it later today in two hours.
So yeah, for those who are new here, my name is Doki Bird.
I usually stream on YouTube, and I'll be doing another stream on YouTube in two hours.
So I'll be doing a chatting stream, just hanging out with everybody and talking with you guys, so you guys can check me out there.
But it was great streaming again.
I always want to stream, even when I'm, like, traveling.
So yeah, thank you, everyone.
Check me out on YouTube, exclamation point YouTube.
If you want to know when I stream on Twitch, check me out on Twitter.
Anyone support me via other means?
Oh, wait, what is it?
What is it?
Thank you for the 100 biddies epic.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, my P.O.
Box?
On the P.O.
Oh, what do you mean by that?
My P.O.
Box is always on my schedule tweet and also on my YouTube community post.
YouTube about me, so the P.O.
Box is always there.
If you guys ever want to send me stuff, thank you for the biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
What else did I want to say?
If you want to support me via other means, I do have my Hyatt stuff that's still out.
The PC, custom PC cases.
Uh, um, and, um, all the, like, the mouse desk mac and everything and acrylic chimes.
Uh, and also, blah, blah, blah, what else is there to show?
Oh, Gamer Subs.
Use my code DokiBird for 10% off on Gamer Subs.
Hey, I'll see you guys later, everyone.
Uh, I'll figure out who to raid.
Actually, I don't have an ending screen.
Fuck.
Uh, no raid.
Because I forgot to set up an ending screen.
So we just, we're just going to snap out of existence.
Uh, so thank you all for coming.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause your checkup, and move around to get that blood flow.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
Uh, no raid, guys.
We're just going to snap into the void.
Bye-bye, everybody.
Bye!